you know I don't know the it's one of
these feelings that you sense when you
meet somebody and there is a response
that is different and is unique and is
palpable and it then changes over time
in other words the sort of exaltation of
first meeting and fallen in love is I
think everybody would admit different
than the films that you might have after
25 years you know when my wife watches
this they say what he thought of that
but it is and it but after 25 years it
becomes almost a dependence and a sense
of knowing somebody so well that you all
have merged as personalities and know
each other's thoughts and there's a
comfort that that is there which is part
of it and equally important
I don't know if there are either
prescribed paths to redemption or if
there is such a thing and I have no
illusion that I can ever get this piece
of my life to fade significantly to the
background it was too much of media
hysteria about it and I'm not saying
improperly so it's there it's you come
to grips with that all you can do is
step back and say okay move forward and
try to continue to do something useful
and over time perhaps that will cause
people to say okay the other piece of
his life is one aspect by their other
aspects as well but you you can't live
or die everyday thing about Redemption
you have to move forward and try to do
things that are useful and worthwhile
and and learn